c'est un truc rédhibitoire pour vous
tient la règle julien et fifi pariente
booba une c'est quoi le truc c'est
limite soit les ongles sales ah ouais
mais quelqu'un qui n'est pas ce que ça
veut dire qu'il n'est pas soit mieux que
ouais mais bon s'il vient de refaire les
niveaux
assez sur booba bout de leurs mots ces
points a les poils je déteste non une
fois j'avais un copain c'est mignon mais
je suis défait mais initiale qu'il avait
rasé comme ça ici comme ça c'était chaud
le m ah oui oui c'est mignon tu vois
arriver raymond soubie même toit et vous
avez vu ça comme ça c'était sympa j'ai
vu forcément j'ai vu il ya un moment là
il va vers l'essentiel et bé té initial
cmdt t'es pas à l'envers parce que moi
cd m
et raté totalement tu vois hélas il ya
isabelle mourinho va attirer que je
t'avais dit qu'elle ferait de la merde
c'est faux m de quoi jeter c'est trop de
poils qui sort assez de l'arn la ci de
là
les femmes les femmes adorent
les hommes aussi nommer les ont
complètement arrêté
mais non vraiment con but s'il vous
plaît
je sais pas mais en tous les cas quand
un animateur me demande de lui amener sa
chemise dans sa salle de bain qui était
torse nu ou en caleçon oui je pense qu'à
lui même
[Applaudissements]
et chemise je suis rentré dans la salle
de bains visité en caleçon alors bébé
pardon je faisais mes textes ne m'a
jamais fait ça à moi aussi je les ai vus
en qu'elles sont là bien sûr s'il n'a
pas bu en caleçon
qui va bientôt alors marie ce correctif
ok c'est
sympa tout ça mais c'est un truc
rédhibitoire pour tarek ton fils est
mort je pourrais pas non
[Applaudissements]
mais cet arrêt à l'essor
est vraiment élevé on n'a pas les robien
revient vraiment l'esprit saint
nous revient à l'esprit que c'est viable
sans déconner on dire un bûcheron
ah c'est sûr qu'il va pas couper des
trouve
ça va chercher des bûches a
alors non mes toiles caractères non pas
tant qu'elle est vivante moi ça va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les ondées pied long as well as a way je
suis ravi mais pourquoi il ya des années
déjà comme sans vous dormiez tête bêche
un quad coeur bat secrète belge s'est
réveillée le matin c'était un trio fois
que j'ai regardé donc c'est quoi
angoisser les dents jaunes par contre
j'adore les poils
sur teen d'argent alors une fille qui
était très poilu je sais mais vous avez
peur rien non je ne sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'on se produit pas deux
minutes et qu'on se dise vraiment les
choses voilà une fois ce problème de
beaucoup d'éléments winder plus tôt
beaucoup d'éléments concordants je
trouve j'avais rencontré une fille sur
un site de rencontre était très poilu
elle s'appelait idrissa faisait du
basket les turcs ne s'appelait pas jan
cools
j'avais bien
ça va en parler avec des trémolos dans
la voix
mathieu tu peux venir
le test à venir s'il te plaît
lui il n'aime pas les donjons par contre
il aime les femmes poilus
[Applaudissements]
la madame son parc il ya dans 10 minutes
pour sa peinture à
merci mr sinon je voulais juste avoir le
droit oui alors moi c'est ok ça vous
choque est sirote et pète et qu'elle a
l'accent canadien
mais tu prends vraiment tu vas tomber
sur une meuf comme à
l'habitude de toujours sans penser qu'un
accent canadien c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais c'est pas mal est une grande blonde
et ou si elle un accent canadien se fait
à bernac toutes les deux minutes
71 40 derrière c'est qui ce mec est
serré mais c'est un
gars très sympa où ces baux venant vous
non mais c'est pareil c'est du mans qui
boudent encore c
est en revanche passé des poils qui
enrage adore à la parisienne sera sans
dirait on dirait parce que vous n'avez
pas de fille pulpeuse est poilu
jusque-là et j'adore ça mais vous comme
gilles moi c'est les forte sécrétion
sous les bras
[Applaudissements]
rim et à dia qui est déjà sortie avec
des meubles qu'ils avaient appris
comment elle transpirait 12 mais sans
déconner maladie de rexona avec toi ne
fais pas chier
10 yens mardi
mais c'est une maladie la maladie du
poisson pour richard
et c'est très difficile à guérir vous
donner envie c'est une réalité mais nos
cinq ballons castaldi ton vous voyez
rien alors ça c'est du web ou part au
vote moi je touche et une fois j'ai
rencontré une femme qui avait dû du poil
entre les seins or c'est génial ah non
non
horrible ça lui une animation
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est votre papa jean pierre
[Rires]
bouquet ni moi j'ai du mal avec l'élan
gripen à mes longues épouse mais depuis
quand vous touchez des longues
directement bellota cas connaît un mec
comme avant de la galoche il était comme
as contre une falaise
sans déconner
et oui oui comme les jambes de chars et
ce à quoi les langues de chat série pin
à parler l'anglais que vous faites le
mais sur les longues les feux
ça m'est déjà arrivé oui à
cette technique évoqué ce qui vous
dégoûte alors je vous dire moi je suis
arrivé à un stade où
tous vraiment nous alors moi ce qui me
dégoûte vraiment dans la mauvaise
haleine la série met les pieds
ils viennent quoi ouais c'est ça ouais
ouais